[Musique]
à nous bonjour clément si nous nous
vantons jardin tb d'affiner sa cinquante
ans que nous chantons jardin oui celui
doigt parce que c'est parce panthères
mais est ce que c'est parce que j'ai
l'âge que j'ai là que vous aurez un beau
document 15
retirez vous savez trop loin feu dans le
temps on aimait parce qu'on t'aime tu te
fais nous le portrait qu'en dresse en
panne ou le belge ou essayer de faire un
petit portrait en venant de toi ça va
être très bon
étais je ferai
jardin
[Musique]
rester
avec moi
encore quelques mois
il sera un petit
c'est ça
j'en prends les miennes
jean
très bien ça
pour qu'il soit passé
quoi je suis venu dans ton monte les
marches aujourd'hui je suis à ta
rencontre comme tu es venu à notre
rencontre depuis 60 ans oui et que nous
parlait du morphing un ton père qui est
la langue de moreuil poursuivi cela
c'est important pour toi de de raconter
ton monde nom qui est aussi notre monde
oui je pense que derrière pour moi
écrire c'était essentiellement parler de
ce qui m'entourait parler de ce qu'on ne
m'ait jamais l'evam et puis ça c'était
c'était mon inspiration naturel et
vergers contre les soeurs et puis mais
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup c'est vrai parler
des femmes parce que je les aime pas tu
as parlé des femmes parce que tu les
aimes je lui racontais dans leurs
membres dans leur vie ordinaire oui dans
leur humilité aussi beaucoup pour leurs
conditions exactement surtout à notre
époque les hommes étaient très très
travaillée à l'extérieur les femmes
restaient toujours à la maison avec les
enfants
et puis le bonhomme rentrée puis ça
soyez à table puisque ce service
babe aux bombers et les maires servette
ou du temps et avait beaucoup beaucoup
d'enfants et on n'avait jamais entendu
nommé 7c existence extraordinaire parce
que pour nous est envoyé à notre mère
qui faisait tous et toutes les mers et
toute la paroisse du 10è c'était pas des
gens riches alors ces gens là qui
travaillaient dans des dans des usines
on les avait jamais chanté et ça c'est
l'idée première que j'ai eu et temps
voisine justement de fac tri dans la
classe des factures et des usines et que
je les rencontrais tout le temps j'ai eu
envie de parler d'elle
est-ce que puis ont peut-être cru pour
constituer parce que ça fait quand même
oui il ya des années qu'on site web ce
n'est pas habituel qu'on fait mais parce
qu'on sent que tu es clémence tuer notre
clément
oui si je pense que ton public aussi a
put d'aborder comme ça comme si tu étais
oui parce que tu as écrit pour lui puis
a même pas ça te faisait un grand
bonheur et le public ne disait souvent
qui fait partie de la famille parce que
c'est vrai ce que je raconte est gelée
piqué par exemple à la à la mère de
louise mon ami j'avais fait un numéro
c'est quand les chiffres chanter changé
à la télévision et le 2 était devenu
tout mais là dedans encore cinq ans à
ses seins oui maintenant whishaw mairie
medasys est alors j'avais écrit mais
voyons mal de n'existe pas à 10 le deux
fermes et non non le 2 et l audi de
distribuer 2 2 jeudi
c'est alors que la fée du spectacle à
vienne trouvait et a dit tu m'as pendant
qu je n'ai peut-être pas se transposer
cette inspiration la de raconter les
gens de ton monde de ton environnement
c'était leur rendre un bel hommage en
main pendant et avec poésie tout le
temps oui sûrement il faut bien que
quelqu'un la nomme celles qui parlent
toujours moi ça j'ai écrit ça quand il
crie beaucoup et l'écriture pour toi
qu'est ce que ça représentait ce besoin
du je suis né en fait dans une maison
remplie de livres et surtout rempli d'un
poète qui prenait beaucoup de place et
qui nous restait à près de 20 des vers
de baudelaire rimbaud à pleine tête et
sow et la maison était plein de livres
donc je suis né avec mes frères et
soeurs avec des livres est notre père
nous nous a fait connaître des écrivains
et rond on prenait les livres des
bibliothèques des fois ça peut être
notre âge mais j'ai déjà dû la faire
durer fût-ce au matin
cela m'était bonne observation à l'école
des floralies quand j'étais là pour
j'étais très très bonne en composition
française anna place à des compositions
et j'étais bon en récréation
donc c'est vrai t'as vu comme c'est
exactement sa composition la récréation
est exact de l'humour et de la poésie
pour nahla fleury nous faire rire c'est
toi c'est les deux facettes de clément
ouais c'est curieux quand j'ai voulu
faire de la scène je n'ai jamais pensé
que je serais quelqu'un qui ferait que
rire mais comme j'ai commencé avec ce
que tout jeune débutant je devrais
savoir radio canada alors les gens et
non classés aux est comique mais quand
j'ai voulu commencer à chanter mes
poèmes que je faisais faire naître en
musique par des bons musiciens comme par
exemple la première chanson que j'ai
fait
on était dans un club et plus je
chantais t'occupes pas de notre espèce
ça passera ça passera et ils s'agrippent
la probable parce que c'est la tristesse
et locales en restait là un ancien
talvern les gars qui allait prendre la
bière la jante est occupée pas de la
tristesse c'est l'intérêt savoir
certaines fuites que j'avais finira pas
toujours facile maintenant
parce que l'époque dont une parle de
l'enfance à tes débuts tu comment
étaient partis vers montréal à 17 ans
oui c'est le conservatoire positionne au
ras du canada tout ça mais cette époque
là d'une époque
effervescence tout à fait et la
révolution tranquille et avec le
sentiment que quand on penserait à toi
un jour que c'était une pionnière que tu
t'es d'avant garde que tu es ce que tu
es incarner la modernité et la liberté
parce que tu penses
n'ont ils pas pensé ça quand on est sur
scène et 4 on fait des spectacles
la chose qui nous préoccupe c'est de
trouver le bon sujet après ça c'est de
l'écrit et après de passer sur scène et
que ce soit un succès mais on ne pense
pas que je suis bonne et et dans
quelques années j'aurais une belle
médaille en l'assemblée nationale pas ma
place en tant qu'usagers plusieurs
médailles c'est de la façon de glisser
lorsque je pense quand on rendait ainsi
hommage de contact arrière quand tu as
aimé
oui oui j'ai été aimé beaucoup et j'ai
jamais fait des salles de chenil
mais beaucoup beaucoup de fidélité à
accompagner ma vie et j'ai reconnu
souvent les mêmes personnes dans la
salle et énormément de femmes et j'étais
vraiment l'artiste chantait les femmes
mais en même temps en décrivant la
condition féminine en parlant aux femmes
des personnages sont des femmes au
dessus l'impression d'avoir contribué à
la révocation partielle
il ya beaucoup de femmes qui m'ont dit
que ça l'aurait appelée c'est du bien
quand je parlais contre les soeurs parce
qu'il y avait subi la même chose des
mêmes choses que moi
2 par 2 par ordre de grandeur et puis
silence mesdemoiselles fragile
autant oui alors c'est peut-être puiser
directement dans une vie que qu'elle
venait de celle de mon âge c'est ce
qu'elle venait de l'iss et pour moi
c'était une façon de me venger et
dessert qui m'avait tellement fait suer
que j'ai écrit en voulant me venger et
j'étais content que les filles soient
d'accord avec moi est-ce que tableau
inspiré ma mère oui ma mère était une
femme plutôt discrète mais avec un
repère comme alfred desrochers dans une
maison ça prend beaucoup de place mais
moment avait un sens de l'humour
extraordinaire et puis quand elle a eu
six enfants elle en a perdu 1 et elle et
moi on était on a fini par être seul
dans la maison à ce que peut pas été
souvent soit à la tarière me soit
ailleurs et puis alors maman et moi on a
on était très très souvent ensemble
puisque toutes les fêtes les autres
s'étaient mariés et j'ai chanté beaucoup
moment mouais ma mère mon ami et parfois
mon enfant avec les mots d'alfred tous
très attachés encore à ta mère a
beaucoup je n'ai jamais oublié c'est
comme si elle était encore vivant c'est
parce que la personne qui occupe mon
esprit le plus c'est elle
si à quelque chose qui me blesse je sais
bien qu'elle n'est plus et je sais bien
que l est plus vivante
mais les dents dans le souvenir et c'est
ma compagne s'émousser mon appui c'est
mon amour pour toujours parce que parti
ça fait longtemps un parfait innocent
soit sincère quand elle est partie j'ai
76 et les mortes de cancers auxerre
vous et ça a été très très pénibles et
moi maintenant je suis plus âgé que ma
mère ouais dans les beaux souvenirs de
ton enfant serait quoi allez vous
souvenir de l'enfance c'était les mois
de juin juillet temps n'y avait pas
d'école ça c'était bonnard parce que
j'étais pas heureuse à l'école j'étais
ordinaire bon nombre de matières et la
rigueur la discipline mais la donne est
l'examen et des clous et tout ça et tout
ce qui était maladies de peau alors
jetés parce que chez nous on était très
très libre est arrivé demain on fait ce
qu'on veut
et à part ça se faire dire le moindre
geste silence pierre coureuse de
corridas recours aux deux rues plus tard
ça fait une vie est riche alors que chez
nous on perd mais ma mère ne nous
laissent faire ce qu'on voulait et on
faisait rien d'excessif sur la petite
rue pacifiques à cherbourg ça te définis
beaucoup oui oui oui le pacifique c'est
ma chambre d'un et soler la factrice
et puis je voyais travailler les
ouvriers et c'est une
c'est une des premières chansons que
j'ai écrites
la directrice et fut pas une chanson à
grande portée sociale la vue de chaque
rue oui moi je
je rencontrais beaucoup de mal à l'école
aller retour les demoiselles céleste qui
je travaillais là et j'ai eu l'idée
d'écrire du demandeur élèves c'est un
poème aimerait seulement temps où
évoluent les demoiselles seles et le
coton flotte en boule blanche
il vient se coller aux cheveux dans le
temps humide et frais du une forte odeur
d'huile ans fidèle au jour qui vont et
passent comme hier aujourd'hui repasse
le lusine à la menace passe la grand
maigre et la courte grâce elles sont
habillées de loire de la boîte à lunch
au chapeau le bas de leurs trous l'ont
entouré le sable des trottoirs les 16
ans passent sans changer la grande
marche un peu de vin l'hiver pour
protéger du vent pour faire un peu
d'ombré l'été elles s'en vont elles
reviennent deux ombres noires sur
fonderie ne font images de leur vie
que dirait tel de lanières clémence
l'entendre dire ta poésie ce sens auquel
tu habites poésie là chaque instant
toujours oui je t'en souviens bien tout
est ma foi et la gitane et d'avoir en
tête le nom de l'époque
non mais as-tu l'impression que l'image
qu'on a que certains ont de toi parce
que ton oeuvre monumentale sur 60 ans
quelle image qu'on peut avoir de toit
celle que fait plus fort que jamais j'ai
chaud des ferries oui oui mais que
l'humoriste clémence enfin petit peu
dans bras japonais tu as tu l'impression
oui j'ai je suis reconnu plus que pour
une fille qui fasse rire que qu'une sait
qui a écrit des poèmes se sait sur une
chanson c'est un poème et puis moi j'ai
été élevé dans la poésie
c'était normal pour moi qui donnait
forme mais c'est tout un travail ça va
passer les extrêmes et écrire des rimes
travailler quand j'ai écrit la vie de
s'attribuer la fin c'était j'ai mis des
semaines à la halle à trouver se disait
maintenant j'ai plus rien à vous dire je
suis pas un sujet à chansons mais ces
deux verres là je t'aime à une misère je
pense juge je restais des mois
je voulais trouver quelque chose qui je
savais que la vie de factrice c'était
une chanson un peu à la manière de
rester debout à des vieilles chansons
françaises
simple mais tu chantes jours et je
voulais je voulais qu'elle soit finie
solide depuis hier voici maintenant j'ai
plus rien à vous dire je suis pas un
sujet à chansons c'est pas mal c'est ce
que ça dit
si je pouvais mettre tout à boutons le
chemin la factrice maison
je serai
y a pas de doute
mme zewde belle au chapeau
pourtant à cause de mes hommes
à vous décrire
partout
je vois la main les choses en poule 1
dit qu'il fait noir
tous
c'est quoi
à temps
mais si comme dans l'accident
la cloche sonne
il n'y a plus qu'une chose que je désire
très vite
maintenant j'ai plus rien à vous dire
j'suis pas sujet en sont
[Musique]
vous dire c'est bon ce que tu sais
clémence méchante pour avec un cri du
coeur alors que les chansons sont dit je
vais chanter pareil avec la douceur de
la voile à travers les chansons que nous
donne beaucoup de douceur
oui beauté ouais la nature cct et j'aime
j'aime chanter
vous avez quitté le lac en septembre
c'était bien trop tôt tiré les rideaux
et fermé les chambres il fait encore
beau c'est beau parce que c'est des
phrases courtes et simples mais j'essaie
de d'en dire beaucoup
vous avez quitté le lac en septembre oui
si nous devenons vos amis je t'emmène
rien dimanche 6 et des mousses à la
maison en bois de plancher pour l'homme
de ta ville rencontré l'homme de ma vie
qui n'aura pas cette maison est
importante pour toi ben c'était c'est
une histoire triste parce que c'est un
petit chat n'est que j'avais acheté
j'avais commencé à faire des sous à la
télévision et je leur avais acheté un
chalet dans le nord est à peine lyon ils
ont été 1 en maman a eu ce cancer alors
ils ont ils opté et c'est là que pape a
écrit ses élégies j'entreprendrai
d'animer seul le paysage où vécut notre
amour pour la dernière fois
j'évoquerai le lac le chalet et les bois
dont rêvait pour ça fait notre
vieillesse s'agit c'est beau même feu et
puis il était seul à la com
il ne pouvait pas être seul dans son
chalet si loin il se tenait beaucoup à
la taverne
alors j'ai été le chercher plus souvent
taverne pour elle
finalement on ne vend que jallet clément
smic si nous recevoir justement dans ton
grand grand jardin dans ton univers dans
ton monde brésil avec moi quel beau la
quinquennale
quel beau paysage les cantons-de-l'est
de la mission se retrouve avec clémence
pour se souvenir
après la pause et sa poésie à tout
si nous devenons bons amis
je
on voit le floch
hélas
de ma vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
clémence en 60 ans de carrière vous
offrir mais tu nous a fait pleurer aussi
tu nous a émus pas su faire notre
portrait ah oui ce qui est reconnu dans
ce que j'écris parce que plusieurs se
sont reconnus et doit chanter l'amour de
chanter les prospects laminant connu la
nature oui les femmes
ouais l'amour des femmes ça a été un
moment je pense important dans ce que
j'écris
pourquoi mais ça c'est ya très longtemps
pauline julier me disais pourquoi tu
chantes pas l'amour de deux femmes mais
jeudi
j'étais pas vrai le public n'était pas
pour elle
j'ai dit je l'écrirai un jour mais je ne
sens pas que c'est le moment est plus
tard qu'un temps quand j'ai vécu
longtemps avec louise et [ __ ] on a
pris de l'âge aussi j'ai écrit les deux
vieilles l'été quand il fait beau soleil
je vois souvent passer de vieilles qui
marche en se tenant le bras elle
s'arrête à tous les discours quand
j'entends leur éclat de rire j'ai un peu
moins peur de vieillir mais j'ai peur et
donc les deux vieilles c'est louise et
toi oui mais je t'ai entendu où j'ai vu
que tu avais déjà dit moi je suis pas
lesbienne
si louise que j'aime c'est tout court si
luis et ça parce que tu des grandes
scènes d'amour aussi d'amour oui la
ville depuis cette année ville depuis
cgt à 7 ans avec un an un amant anglais
et quand ils me laissent est tombé c'est
lui qui a dit de m'en aller j'ai écrit
la ville depuis c'est adieu adieu berthe
à la ronde qui jacassent est sur le
palier
ce pourra dire à tout le monde ce modèle
que ces casses et adieu adieu obertan la
ronde qui jacquat serait sur le
un palier
tu pourras dire à tous
ça m'a bien là
[Musique]
que c'est
quand
c'est
là
un allah
cependant mon amour peut pas ça veut pas
dire de la place ville-marie gens
portent encore toutes les marques
surtout un vertige infinie ils
flottaient des drapeaux en bas la même
ville le même rue
j'ai eu peur de tomber dessus mais je
gardais le vide en moi quand je veux
noyer mon chagrin
je vais me perdre chez idole on voit
jamais pu le pleure et personnes sur le
comptoir des magasins je prends la vie
d'un peu moins haut
je me promène au cimetière et je
rappelle à ma misère qu'elle ne pourra
pas faire diego s'est amusé le poste 2
adieu adieu berthe là où je dois aller
vers même pas que la mort de ta mère je
pense oui c'est exactement je m'habille
l'étudier ces méfaits portefeuille de
deuil
c'était terrible parce que de raison et
alors je pleure et puis maman était
désespérée et un soin elle dit viens on
va aller le tuer ce qu'il faut ce qu'il
à la menthe et les pouilles annonces
surviennent avant la marque elle épouse
c'est un extrait degers les spectacles
que j'ai fait avec quatre piliers et pas
n'importe lesquels non mais ça traverse
et louise latraverse qui avait eu l'idée
a dit quoi il les gosses en sont à
pourquoi nous laisser aux notes sans
humour pourquoi on n'en serait pas chaud
ici j'étais au petit d'accord je vais
vous le mets d'abord qu'il était légale
j'avais pour le bal à chantal renaud
louise latraverse diane dufresne et moi
ça s'appelait lakers et la menthe et les
pousse et ça vient de salades viandes et
c'était cousineau qui avait écrit la
musique en soit françois cousineau est
la première comédie musicale au québec
le samedi la passer dans le vert mais le
premier mois ça s'appelait le vol rose
du diamant moi j'avais écrit le vol du
flamant rose et mon père m'a dit il ya
un
ce qui s'appelle le flamant rose est un
peu peureux m'empêche il dit tu devrais
appeler ça le voir aux flamands c'est
beaucoup plus joli
alors la fille de son père alors ça mais
c'est à peu près la seule fois qu'il m'a
aidé mais alors tout rencontre première
comédie musicale tahiti bon la fac trim
deux bandes s'étaient c'était la
première affaire des monologues à portée
sociale
tu écris les deux vieilles dont elle est
le dire aussi comme une femme pour
essayer d'être heureuse et tout ça
plutôt vers aussi le patriote pas
tellement c'est toi que lolita première
chance
ils vont des chats ils vont deschamps
commencé avec moi diane dufresne jeu des
beaux souvenirs une belle époque ce
n'est pas intéressant
écoute moi j'ai dit en parlant entre
amis de ces années 50 de 7,1 à l'époque
où la télévision a commencé à ouvrir ses
portes aux variétés à nous faire
connaître
après ça on a fait des boîtes à chansons
les bozos ce qui a fait qu'on n'a bien
dans notre vie et il y avait une
création on a commencé avec ferlin
léveillée a parlé de nous a chanté le
pays
ouais mais toi tu n'étais pas
nécessairement politique mais simplement
donc j'ai écrit de ton sujet que tu
était la première à écrire des chansons
en langue québécois oui la ville depuis
oui c'est une des chansons qui
représentait la ville mais vraiment le
québec moderne le québec et du moment et
parler comme nous
ouais oui lorsque j'ai fait mon
conservatoire conservatoire mais on
était trop fermé qui disent comprendre
et je suis sorti du conservatoire parmi
les et cetera et puis j'ai cherché du
travail en alla à radio canada on
faisait au frapper à la porte
bon je m'appelle m 1 0 chez j'ai
beaucoup de talent c'est vrai ce travail
est est ce que vous pensez de g j'ai de
la chance mais c'était une femme j'ai
dit je crois vraiment que j'ai l'appel a
dit on vous appellera quand ils m'ont
alors c'est très drôle
ben justement à tenir sans avoir été
trop humble tout au long de sa carrière
non non non moi j'arrivais sur scène
j'étais vraiment c'est le plus beau
moment de ma ville les spectacles
étaient bons les salles pleines oui elle
rassurante sur scène avec son bel habit
neuf soudan quand on habite celle des
tout sens belle étudiante applaudi
[Musique]
c'est vraiment debout j'ai vécu une vie
intense et très belle à cause à cause
des spectacles déjà décrypté spectacle
comme time sur scène c'est comme un feu
intérieur
oui et ce que j'ai aimé de ça c'est que
ça fait que ça n'est plus toi très lente
et chagrins été déçu quand je fais
roland des amis elles travaillent toutes
les deux pour la même compagnie
alors moi je n'oublie que j'ai une peine
parce que ma grande servi à nourrir dans
certains voyaient cet envol cet envoi du
conservatoire ça te revois dans un autre
monde et c'est comme ça que j'ai
commencé quand j'étais tout petit à me
dire moi je vais faire une actrice parce
que c'était pas facile toujours chez
nous mon enfance et on avait fait une
petite séance était en charge et sur
saint léger du mon petit texte plus les
gens ont ri ça m'a tellement transporter
je me suis dit il existe un autre monde
que le réel monde dans lequel on est sur
la rue pas ce fait je vais essayer de le
retrouver cette façon et je suis sûr que
j'allais au conservatoire le tacoma
savais tu que les monologues su écrire
et frairie autant l'aja qui adapte et
jacky de papier c'est ça te fait
d'actualité un site web petite chaise le
faire la claque à l'air qui espèrent
gallas a tenu bon chien la petite jackie
un papier les pentes enfin papier c'est
un panier avec la ville et la cac qui
sont je suis toujours un mariage surtout
je te dis que chaque fois que je faut
que j'aille à l'hôpital sam à malherbe
j'ai dû changer ma d'hôpital il n'en
n'est pas question madame parce que j'ai
dit pourquoi parce que on assiste à un
rapport de force entre un milieu qui
veut protéger l'autonomie de sa pratique
de sa politique les technocrates de la
santé qui veulent imposer leurs
directives aux hôpitaux
ça m'a fait un bien immense d'apprendre
[Applaudissements]
à toi statut cesse de faire la claque à
l'air puis espère mais je crois que les
échelles sont plaints à genève à huy
leur mieux mais tu es là tu as raté ta
tâche et se tourner en arrière où j'ai
d'arghandab
mais s'il voulait venir mais aidé ça
c'est encore deux puis trois par chambre
dans des hôpitaux mobiles n'ont plus le
droit de fumer mais quand même comme les
bleus dans la doit voilà il ya il ne
faire le ménage te dis que ça y est la
vue j'ai vu c'était bruit hier que les
centres d'accueil ah oui ça les centres
d'accueil c'est d'actualité par le tuc
un que j'ai écrit ce fait quand même
assez longtemps parce que j'ai les
derniers spectacles
gn et que j'ai une envie qu'ils
accueillent beaucoup j'avais mes classes
est allé jouer mais le plus beau
spectacle dont je me souviens c'est le
dernier avec marie michèle desrosiers et
c'était on a en a eu un peu de foot
c'est un spectacle inc il y brille avec
des bons musiciens qui avaient un peu
jazz il y avait marine chef chante si
bien elle jouait avec moi un texte
qu'elle faisait quand je faisais jeanne
d'arc une faible
à force on peut dire comment cette image
que son nom était très drôle et elle
chante elle chante merveilleusement bien
et puis c'est un spectacle qui se
déroulait qu'il n'y avait pas de liliane
est pas tout alors notre grand nom notre
grand le plamondon était venue était
sorti en disant ce spectacle vaut cinq
étoiles j'étais bien fonds table parce
que toi qui avait menacé de prendre ta
retraite
ouais akbar presse avait à peine 40 ans
bien 67 ce que je fais courrier de 19 de
ses profits ni clémence on va revenir
avons conçu notre conversation dans un
instant a redit tout à toi quelques
secondes quelques minutes on va revenir
de la mission avec les masses tout se
tapent à la porte
ok
[Musique]
efi
déjà de vraiment vraiment nourri ma vie
et maintenant on va aller faire l on
fait des trucs là ça s'est terminé en
beauté
oui spectacle comme s'ils rêvaient ah
oui nous devons voir au public de la fin
mai ah oui et vraiment c'est pas permis
gt gt contente et puis je savais que
c'était vraiment le dernier comme tu te
disais j'en ai fait plusieurs mais celui
là je savais que je reviendrais plus sur
scène parce que je fatigue et et puis
j'en ai assez la fin ça fait le tour tu
sais ça quand même
avant quand je disais j'arrête je
m'ennuyais mais maintenant je m'ennuie
plus du tout de la scène je fais
d'autres je fais des dessins que je
trouve très jolie mais qui se vendent
pas bien un très jolie exposition qui a
été créé à sherbrooke - et qui se
promènent maintenant depuis que je ne
fais plus de show j'aime beaucoup
dessiné mon ami rené jacques homme
envoyé beaucoup de d'anciennes photos de
sa jeunesse
je m'en suis inspiré pour faire des
dessins mais j'ai beaucoup de chats
ouais et dechy et d'oiseaux mais j'adore
les chats d'avis mais chaque joute m
alors le bon vieux duke a choisi etc
j'ai toujours aimé les chats j'en ai
toujours mû peut déjà vu que paye ses
écrits mais pour parer ce c'est vrai
mais c'est jaillit écrire qu'un dans la
chanson c'est surtout en été quand je
pourrai partir avec mon bateau puis que
je suis là avec mon petit cahier puis un
mail à l'écriture
donc la finesse de l'écriture de la
poésie c'est essentiellement ce que tu
voudrais qu'on retient de toi oui
j'aimerais qu'on retienne quelques
jeunes de mes chansons est ce que c'est
ça se fait totalement des tapis belles
chansons parce que ça se fait non ma
plus belle chanson est ce que je peux
dire que j'ai réussi
non c'est peut-être la ville factrice
oui d'avoir pensé écrire la vie patrie
c'est plus trouvé c'est plus unique mais
c'est une forme d'engagement il n'y pas
on revient à cette idée le monologue de
la chanson peut devenir ça a été écrit à
ton sujet une norme sociale
il faut dire quelque chose oui faut
avoir quelque chose à dire qu'ils
touchent qui est vrai et puis on peut
faire en même temps des folies
moi j'adore ferrières les gens quand une
salle pleine
kiri quelques que c'est c'est vraiment
extraordinaire mais je suis content
d'être capable de deux d'écrire des
poèmes que se contente d'être capable de
passer justement de faire pleurer puis
d'abord parce que c'est ça la vie la vie
c'est ça on est joyeux mais joyeux bagne
nous arrivent en fr plates ou alors la
mort de quelqu'un qu'il ya toujours des
amics avant qu'il y en a de plus en plus
cela trouble nommément oui oui but est
de venir dès le départ des amis seront
ni claude que j'aimais la dernière fois
je les ai vues elles et elles sortaient
d'un spectacle était encore à ses billes
et puis j'étais vers elle que je lui
dirai je t'aime qui s est penché dans
mon oreille elle dit clémence je t'aime
d'amour c'est beau chanceuse puisque
cette angoisse à ce projet là oui amélie
ah oui oui parce que dans les deux
vieilles dit on s'aime toujours on va
partir de mai juin métier s'éteindre et
s'éteint c'est un rêve
oui je crois pas que ça arrivera il a
fait encore des rêves
des rêves non en vieillissant ces faits
je suis moins angoissé que je l'étais
j'ai un fond tristesse moi tu n'habites
et puis en vieillissant il ya une chose
qui m'obsède c'est que je suis rendu à
86 ans qui contre le reste de temps du
temps c'est à fois là alors je pense
beaucoup beaucoup à ça que j'ai que j'ai
l'âge que j'ai pigé le prend pas on le
sent pas du tout
moi j'avais pas de ta je sais pas moi
alors jeudi les chiffres à l'envers oui
la pire affaire que j'ai vécues
récemment c'est la mare de magrin eh oui
oui elle est là une mort je vous
raconterai pas ça c'est trop triste mais
ça a été long long long long sault c
c'est tragique parce qu'en plus 513 en
attaque pire puisqu'ils portent tous les
souvenirs de l'enfance ou si wes consent
que pour toi
la trame de l'amour que deux chambres
des personnes le père la mère la famille
leulier n'importe pas oui oh oui oui
j'ai une maison on était six et en inde
il reste 3
le plus jeune des 85 le bébé de la
famille haqqani ce faire on ne pas
parler de cinéma
mais nombre de faits j'en ai pas fait
beaucoup mieux la grande séduction mais
oui presque libye
hippie prenez poursuit jusqu au bout
pour que si quilici je rêve
j'aimerais ça avoir avoir un rôle au
cinéma pas écrit par moi non mais
sérieux personnage qui serait différent
- et le cinéma dit que j'aurai le
premier rôle oui le premier rôle autre
manon j'aime bien moi les films inspirés
des écrivains bah oui parce qu'il ya un
fond est ce que peut-être que ça
arrivera j'en doute
donc on va mettre des jeunes
réalisateurs de coûts d'ici au défi oui
qu'est-ce que tu as aimé le plus au
monde au monde ces moments c'est ma mère
ouais quand il appert cet homme mûr qui
s'effondre parce que si celle ci a de
l'amour c'est l'amour le puits le plus
fort parce que moi ma mère c'était ma
mère comme gimat même mon ami et parfois
mon enfant je pouvais tout lui dire je
vais moi j'avais un homme a des fois je
me cherchais une ou deux fois chez avec
lui mais c'est surtout à être payé at il
quand est ce que les hommes de main du
maire ou malheureux oh non j'ai eu deux
trois amants j'ai eu un anglais et j'ai
eu un noir et puis est sorti avec une
[ __ ] en étant moi même
d où je ne savais pas lui savait qu'ils
étaient mieux à la peau qu'elle lui il
était co brantus clémence la pionnière
la peau est l'humoriste l'écrivaine
l'artiste complet une oeuvre à portée
sociale mais jamais politique
non tu voulais pas tout la politique
m'ennuie énormément alors ce qui
m'ennuie m'inspire pas du tout
l'impression d'avoir eu de l'aude
oui ça je pense que chante il demande à
sa sortie du conservatoire
et puis je n'avais pas de travail alors
mais j'ai tellement sûr que c'est ça que
j'allais faire être sur scène et j'ai
fais je le fais faire ma mère un petit
costume allah allah
tout même marceau j'avais des collants
noirs et puis tu as fait un velours
moment m'avait fait ça puis j'avais à me
faire photographier par un professionnel
j'avais pas de travail nulle part et
c'est comme ça je me présentais que je
savais faire du mime alors que jaillit
de même
et puis je voulais tellement tellement
que ce soit sur ma vie sur scène j'avais
de parler de choses près ce que tu es
bout de laure de choisir parle aux mains
de parler de la même la ménopause on
parle pas de ça avant moi il ya une
certaine
moi j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour la
belgique oui elle s'en était une
pionnière dans les conditions de vie
qu'elle menait avec des enfants s'en
allait faire chanter ses chansons qui
sont loin d'être bête et elle était à
errer métro avec un travail avait de
munich et denise mais c'était plutôt de
les sketches comiques
alors que j'ai voulu moi raconter ce
qu'on vivait avec humour et sérieusement
aussi mais vivre la vie pendant que je
la vivais l'a raconté à ai raconté ce
qui me ressemble est ce ce que j'aime et
ce que j'aime pas la vie telle qu'elle
se déroulait pour moi et pour ceux qui
m'entourent il monte à la femme de son
époque
voilà berne au dessus l'impression que
même si de temps à voir c'est par la
vieillesse belle maman et poussa à
dessus l'impression 3 80e femme vit
maintenant à la tpu lille que jamais oui
à la liberté de n'ouvrir de penser à ce
que je n'ai plus jeune et je n'ai plus
d'exigences 4t faire du spectacle c'est
que les soirs c'est ce 18 se disent
c'est déguisé
bon c'est une contrainte et c'est un
tract ou le thym solitaire d'antiques là
je suis très très libre y'a rien qui
m'empêche ya rien qui matin il y avait
trois qui m'attendait ou mais j'étais
très content tu viens me voir
les plus beaux souvenirs actuellement il
y en a plusieurs beaucoup beaucoup de
beaux souvenirs avec louise et qui est
mon ami depuis 50 ans et puis des boues
souvenirs avec l'amitié
je crois beaucoup à l'amitié
quand je suis devenue orpheline mais
quelqu'un m'a dit à 87 à peu près
normale et ma vie et ce qui m'intéresse
c'est beaucoup beaucoup les autres
l'amitié puis un dernier mot peut-être
sur le fait que couler oui oui on l'a
vécu les symboles t'as pas ce que je
faisais mon à la gaîté cherchait
toujours mes mots bien entendu alors ce
collège est ce qui vient après thomas
ouais mais la cool et ça te pose
souffler les réponses aujourd'hui n'a
pas dit où c'est la clémence et notre
clémence
qu'est ce que les femmes pourraient de
dire les femmes à qui tu as parlé que tu
as des cris qu'est ce qui te fait le
plus plaisir qu'elle te dire quelques
mots j'en ai souvent et de très beaux
compliments je rencontre des gens vous
m'avez fait du bien mais hier elles ont
un défaut ce qu'elle me touche tout le
temps et ça j'aime pas ça parce qu'elle
ne rend-il edwards et l'homme et
monétaires mais mon état de fait et
c'est beaucoup beaucoup de des femmes et
j'en reçois des des très belles lettres
et d'aider des choses importantes qu'ils
font que j'ai peut-être une raison
d'exister
alors merci clément
merci notre clémence merci pour ton
jardin
merci pour ton bon travail pour que je
sais que tu m'a fouillée
merci beaucoup de tout et bellamy et
c'est pour finir là messieurs merci
d'avoir été à notre rendez vous avec
clémence la prochaine
les vielles quand t'es fait beau soleil
je vois souvent bas c'est lui
kima
chance
elle s'arrête à tous les niveaux
quand j'entends leur école
j'ai
un peu moins peur de vieillir
[Musique]
c'est la chanson que je nous change se
rende vieille dame en resterons nous
tendre complices
[Musique]
il était qu'à paris
non sacré numéro
le chat
on le sait
oh
[Musique]
c'est
je
je ne
[Musique]